are some polling done in 2018 that found
that roughly two-thirds of Brits would
put off medical appointments because
they didn't want to get bad news so a
genuine sense of fear and look you can
ask like what came first this
nervousness or the NHS telling them not
to show up I suppose this is kind of a
vicious circle if you don't have a
system that gives you preventative kinds
of Health Care and really only sees you
when you are very sick well then it's
quite natural that you're afraid to go
to the doctor because you are afraid to
get bad news because things may have
progressed past a point where maybe if
you caught it earlier things would be
slightly better part of this is the
American in May Americans like to
consume health care but I think I have
the rest of the world backing me up on
this one too I think Britain's neighbors
I think virtually all developed
countries look at the UK and are baffled
because on the one hand everyone in the
UK holds up universal access to health
care it's like crowning Jewel of Britain
and yet its residents do everything they
can to stay away from that so-called
universal access